brought to you by rise of the Tomb
Raider twenty year celebration now
available on ps4 video games allow us to
do slightly cruel and unusual things
that we wouldn't get away with in real
life like drowning families in a pool by
taking away the ladder opening that
rollercoaster to the public but
neglecting to finish the track first or
capturing an innocent bystander and
leaving them hogtied on the tracks all
lovely completely normal gaming memories
now in this episode of reality check is
brought to you by rise of the Tomb
Raider which is now available on ps4 it
also happens to coincide with the 20th
anniversary of the Tomb Raider series
the blood ties DLC takes you back to
Clarke Manor which you'll remember as
the scene of a crime most wicked you
know the one where you lock the butler
and a giant meat locker and let him miss
fries so inspired by gaming's most
famous case of elder abuse I decided to
look into what would actually happen if
you were to lock a frail but faithful
old man into a walk-in freezer or just
anyone into a walk-in freezer for that
matter and what you should do if that
situation would ever happen
my job is weird
so the first thing to do is to get some
details on the poor old chap how much is
really sad about the Crofts loyal Butler
in the Tomb Raider gained he just
menacingly follows you around with a
rattling tray full of tea so I had to
look elsewhere for his vitals French
company editions atlas released a
magazine called the official fact files
back in the 90s and not only did it come
with collectible figurines of everyone's
favorite acrobatic aristocrat but they
had identity cards for characters that
Lara ran into on her travels one of
those was one Winston Smith Butler
extraordinaire to the Croft family the
magazine may refer to him as Jeeves but
it does give his date of birth as
February 7 1927 as Tomb Raider 2 came
out in 1997 that makes Winston a very
distinguished seventy years old so now
we've got Winston's details what our
conditions in the freezer like I guess
you need a lot of protein for all those
acrobatics which must be the reason that
the only thing in Lara's kitchen are
hanging carcasses of meat now given that
according to the Food and Agriculture
Organization of the United Nations meat
carcasses should be frozen at a minimum
of not degrees Fahrenheit or minus 18
degrees Celsius to last at least six
months we can deduce that Winston is in
virtue night he'd face a number of
dangers the start frostbite according to
the British National Health Service
frostbite is damage to skin and tissue
caused by exposure to freezing
temperatures typically any temperature
below minus 0.55 degrees Celsius or 31
degrees Fahrenheit the body responds to
the chill by narrowing blood vessels
blood flow to the extremities slows down
to the blood can reach vital organs
dead without the lovely warm blood
coursing through them extremities like
fingers and toes get colder and fluid
within the tissue can freeze the elderly
are particularly more susceptible to
frostbite because they have less
subcutaneous tissue that's the stuff
under the skin that's used for fat
storage which the body needs to keep
warm a way to prevent frostbite is to
wrap up warm and actually wear that hat
scarf glove and sock sets the amother
knitted you for Christmas she worked
hard on there however it's not that easy
for Winston we can see that he's wearing
his butlering attire and sadly the
uniform doesn't come with thick knitted
items to protect his head and fingers so
it seems that frostbite is a given but
what other dangers lurk inside the
freezer hypothermia occurs when your
body temperature drops below 35 degrees
C or 95 degrees Fahrenheit
normal body temperature is 37 degrees C
or 98.6 degrees Fahrenheit so while this
is only a couple of degrees it could
mean the difference between life and
death there's three stages of
hypothermia mild moderate and severe
depending on how much your body
temperature drops you'll start shivering
and hyperventilating gradually you'll
become confused speech will slur and
you'll lose coordination from there your
pulse weakens and you'll likely fall
unconscious hypothermia doesn't just
happen to people who get locked in
freezers babies and the elderly are also
at risk there have been a few cases
where people have gone out drinking late
at night without wearing appropriate
clothing and developed hypothermia I'm
from Newcastle in the north of England
and I can believe that so make sure you
keep that core temperature up if you're
locked in a freezer try and fashioned
some kind of protection from the cold
create a barrier between yourself and
the floor using cardboard boxes wrap
yourself in layers if you can sadly for
Winston this isn't really an option
Mira's freezer is so sparse he's pretty
much doomed to a bout of hypothermia
that's if he doesn't suffocate first
this is not a cheery one is it the
freezer bunker doesn't have any windows
or visible ventilation shaft
meaning that poor ol Winston could
actually suffocate there have been a few
cases where people have become trapped
in freezes and have been overcome by
carbon dioxide fumes from blocks of dry
ice which are sometimes used in giant
walk-in freezers to preserve food if the
main freezer mechanism is broken
basically when we locked Winston in the
freezer we doomed him to frostbite
hypothermia and potentially suffocation
and that's not to mention the lack of
food water and the fact that he would
have to go to the bathroom in there too
so yeah now I've made myself feel bad
well this video certainly went some
places if you ever do find yourself
going into a walk-in freezer make sure
that the emergency release works and
tell someone that you're going in there
anyway thanks for watching this week's
episode of reality check you can find me
on Twitter at Lucy James games and for
more videos like this one make sure to
LIKE and subscribe to GameSpot
you